[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new avengers hulk
video
marvel just made a big announcement
about the future of the hulk character
and she-hulk so we'll explain what's
going on they've announced a bunch of
big castings and mark ruffalo himself
has also announced what's going on with
the future of his bruce banner hulk in
marvel phase four
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with the hulk
family of characters anybody from the
hulk comics during marvel phase 4
because there's a bunch of them that
will be showing up pretty soon
so we'll break down all the big hulk
stuff that's coming up starting with the
big stuff first number five
the she-hulk series they confirmed that
tatiana maslany is going to be their
she-hulk for marvel phase four
and future avengers movie crossovers so
even though she-hulk is going to be a
marvel phase 4 series on disney plus
that's going to premiere sometime during
the whole idea with all of the marvel
disney plus series is that they're
connected to
and cross over with movies and will set
up stuff that they'll deal with in the
movies
so there's a little bit of hulk stuff
happening through thunderbolt ross
falcon and winter soldier the super
soldier program the weapons plus
program that's more red hulk thunderbolt
stuff
so the she-hulk series will just
continue that stuff that they set
up in falcon and winter soldier we'll
see a little bit of thunderbolt stuff
during the black widow movie as well
i'll talk about that in a second too
i'm really happy with the casting i
didn't know that she was in the running
but she's a fantastic actress if you
haven't seen any of her stuff orphan
black is probably the best place to go
just because she plays so many different
versions of characters
make all the multiverse jokes you want
if you're not really familiar with the
she-hulk character she's his
cousin in the comics jennifer walters is
bruce banner's cousin and she gets into
an accident she gets a blood transfusion
from him
and gets his gamma irradiated blood
that's how she winds up getting her
powers so
arguably they'll introduce him at the
beginning of the series as a way to give
her her abilities they might change a
little bit about her comic book origin
story but they try to include at least
big easter eggs
about the original version from the
comics but one of the bigger takeaways
here is that mark ruffalo confirmed a
long time ago earlier this year that he
is sticking around to the mcu for the
long haul
his original marvel movie contract still
has one movie left on it before he needs
to renegotiate
based on all the stuff that he said he's
doing is the hulk during marvel phase 4
it sounds like he will have to sign a
new contract to continue being the bruce
banner hulk for marvel
interestingly enough though he did make
it seem like he won't be
a big character again during thor 4 love
and thunder among those projects
even though some of the movie will take
place on earth because new asgard is
still in norway right now
just based on the way he was talking
about it i'm not expecting hulk to show
up for anything more than a very short
cameo
if anything number four the marvel phase
four movies and series that mark ruffalo
confirmed that he's appearing in
just going in order that they're going
to be released starting with
marvel's what if series he's confirmed
for episodes of that he didn't say how
many episodes but the first season of 10
episodes will be released in summer 2021
right after doctor strange ii multiverse
of madness he didn't say if his hulk
episode will be for what if
incredible hulk or for another episode
because kevin feige said
they were doing a what if episode for
every single marvel movie from the
infinity saga
which is 23 episodes total including the
first two spider-man movies spider-man
homecoming and spider-man far from home
spider-man on the disney plus series
gets a little complicated with what
they're allowed to do with the sony
marvel sharing deal and tom holland so
don't worry about that too much right
now this is mostly a hulk video
number three next mark ruffalo said that
he had pitched a new hulk solo series on
disney plus he said the plot of his hulk
series would be very similar
at least in themes to the original
incredible hulk tv series from the 1970s
with bill bixby and lou ferrigno's hulk
there's a big stan lee easter egg in
this too if you guys didn't know
obviously stan lee famous for all of his
cameos and all the different marvel
projects all across the films
but his very first cameo and live action
was on the incredible hulk 1978 tv
series
mark ruffalo said the basic premise of
his incredible hulk tv series would just
be his version of professor hulk after
the events of avengers end game in 2023
on the run again being chased down by
thunderbolt ross and the government
there is word of them doing a lot of
thunderbolts stuff during marvel phase
4. so an easy solution would be to have
thunderbolt ross be the main villain of
that series and just have it be hulk
versus the thunderbolts with all the
biggest marvel villains
teaming up trying to capture the hulk
for six episodes
love the concepts just want to see some
more badass hulk stuff happening during
marvel phase 4 which it sounds like they
do have plans for
number two this is actually probably the
most exciting thing is that mark ruffalo
said that he's pitching kevin feige on a
new hulk vs wolverine movie
he did confirm that there was still kind
of a rights issue with universal so
that's why there's no official date for
any kind of new hulk movie even though
they're trying to work on one
but if there was any confusion mark
ruffalo is really excited to do a hulk
vs wolverine movie it's more a question
of when they can get to that story
worst case scenario they just have to
throw ragnarok it into some other larger
movie with a couple other avengers
characters in the background
the weird technicality of the rights
issue is that they can do whatever they
want to with hulk in
other people's movies they just can't
put hulk in the title of the movie
and arguably if you're going to do hulk
versus wolverine you want to put that in
the title
here's the thing though wolverine just
feels like too big of a character
for them to debut a new version on a
disney plus series first because they
can do
hulk tv shows like he said incredible
hulk solo series that he's pitching
i think it's more reasonable for them to
introduce the concept of the weapon x
program using the thunderbolt ross
character in the disney plus series
just in the background you just find out
that that's been happening this whole
time
in fun fact the weapon x program is
actually just the most recent iteration
of the super soldier program that
started with captain america
so wolverine technically isn't weapon x
he's weapon 10 as in roman numeral x
captain america is designation
weapon one so don't be surprised if they
try to use some
mcu captain america super soldier
mythology when they introduce a new
version of the weapon x program in the
mcu
in thunderbolt ross already had a
version of the super soldier serum in
the incredible hulk movie
there was even a scene where he
explained a quote-unquote
special program that sounded exactly
like the weapon x program
this was that scene you're aware that
we've got an infantry weapons
development program
well in ww2 they initiated a sub
program for biotech force enhancement
yeah super soldier
yes no more simplification but yes
and i dusted it off got him doing
serious work again bold work
banner's work was very early phase
he thought he was working on radiation
resistance i would never have told him
what the project really was
that was from 2008 when they didn't have
any of the x-men rights and couldn't do
big x-men easter eggs but doesn't it
sound like they were writing that as if
thunderbolt ross was conducting the
weapon x
program and this was just part of that
now that they have all the rights to the
x-men characters there are no
limitations they can reference
anything that they want mark ruffalo
also said that he pitched a different
professor hulk movie to marvel this one
was more about the hulk and banner
battling it out for control of his body
remember the avengers infinity saga
deleted scene from infinity war where we
saw a version of that play out during
the big final battle in wakanda
it would be a whole movie for something
like that which does sound cool
i posted that whole deleted scene to my
channel a while ago so i'll link it at
the end of this
but it didn't give any kind of
indication as to who the main villain of
that movie would be
besides hulk and banner just fighting
each other but a lot of you have seen
the thunderbolt ross
red hulk rumors if they really do start
setting that character up after the
black widow movie during marvel phase 4
or a disney plus series
red hulk is a great villain for a hulk
movie easy slam dunk
and because mark ruffalo intends on
coming back during avengers 5
in three to four years whenever they get
to that movie there's always potential
for a dark avengers subplot in marvel
phase five
too but number one of course red hulk
during marvel phase four and avengers 5
what we know right now is that he's
rumored to appear at some point during
the she-hulk series which might sound
strange at first but
if they have the rights to do whatever
kind of hulk tv show that they want
it would make sense that they tease a
lot of hulk-based characters
on the tv shows right now there's no
thunderbolts movie that's happening
during marvel phase 4 but there is a
good chance that after the current batch
of marvel disney plus series the next
two years
they'll announce a thunderbolt series
and that's where you see them do a lot
of red hulk stuff
short answer is there's a lot more hulk
characters coming during marvel phase 4
also falcon winter soldier is supposed
to set up some thunderbolt stuff
and that's going to be the very first
disney plus series coming in august
right now the expected release date of
the she-hulk series will be 2022
sometime that's also probably around the
same year that they wind up releasing
the hawkeye series
i don't know when they plan on releasing
the moon knight series but of course
i'll do more videos about those when we
get more information
let me know in the comments though what
do you guys think about tatiana maslany
playing she-hulk in the mcu and her
showing up in future avengers movies
i know everyone's got all kinds of
theories about her showing up during
spider-man 3 now because spider-man
really could use a lawyer to help him
out now that the government is after him
but the really good news is the other
big character that's coming back is
chris hemsworth's thor
i just did a video he posted a clip of
himself just doing all kinds of funny
stuff talking about coming back in the
avengers
so click here to watch that and click
here for the other big new avengers
movies announcement that marvel just
made about the brand new villain that
just debuted
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
you